hello and welcome to gender 2014 from
January is going to be a busy session as
Parliament returns from the Christmas
break here's a snippet of what's to come
we don't just grid aurevoir to 2013 but
also to lithuania as greece takes over
the rotating council presidency of EU on
Jan Murray the first priorities for the
six months ahead include jobs and growth
migration and maritime policies so can
grease mind its own economic problems
really deliver stability to Europe it
was the solution to prevent another
economic crisis a union that United
Europe's banks and sever the link from
national governments especially
vis-à-vis failing banks good 2014 be the
year we stop talking about it and
actually have a banking Union especially
as parliamentary elections around the
corner well as we wait in see another
highlight will be an inquiry into the
troika the IMF the ECB and the
Commission the report by Parliament's
economic and Monetary Affairs Committee
is expected in may change it's time for
Europe to decide as a 2014 European
parliamentary elections kick off from
the 22nd 25th of May it's shaping up to
be one of the most interesting elections
of a generation as votes will decide
which party gets a field a candidate for
the role of the president of the
Commission keep watching Europe our TVs
election coverage will be with you every
step of the way and here's the big
roundup of stories expected to hit the
headlines in the next semester an
overhaul of work is rights under the
freedom to provide services 1 million of
us move to work in other EU countries
it's over to employment committee to
make a deal by April next is air
passenger lights delays cancellations
denied buildings how many of us actually
take action against airlines or change
as a transfer committee's report to stop
airline abuse ghost a plenary in
February safeguarding non state pension
lights across the EU go to the plenary
in it februari if adopted members dates
have four years to then transpose of
those rules international
all the telecoms package is another
priority for the months ahead with a
deal being pushed for in May better
right privacy internet and clearer
charges could be all yours and finally
talks on climate and energy goal to 2030
I set to resume in the new year with a
vote on report in January lots more to
come but that's all we have for this
agenda enjoyed the holidays and see you
next year